next up it's time for us to review the
things you would like us to you guys
write in for this it's true's reviews hi
i'm looking forward to this one
okay and today we're trying the
shape-shifting salad taking over tick
tock sent in by lucy palmer thanks lucy
it's called the green goddess and it's a
salad disguised as a delicious dip and
it was created by baked by melissa chef
melissa benishai as an easy way to get
your greens down your gullet pronto you
take cabbage iceberg lettuce cucumbers
and chives and chop them all up into
tiny little pieces and then you top it
with a blended dressing of lemons garlic
vinegar and more if you'd like so we're
going to try out this big tick-tock
trend i'm salivating oh oh
mm-hmm mm-hmm really mm-hmm
it's so acidic right
it's like a like a coleslaw meets a
chimichurri or something
whoa i know
they say you're supposed to dip it
rossi are you avoiding the chips
how dare you notice true
i was trying to just eat it without a
chip okay let's try it with that
i gotta go this is amazing
i gotta say it's like a coleslaw yeah
it's a coleslaw
making out with a
um chimichurri you're right about the
chimichurri it's herbaceous
i'm liking it i'm angry because it's so
much better with the chip i have to say
but i'm not doing it i'm warm but it's
it's this is really incredible
i think an avocado in here would be
amazing i think that's what you say like
add your little thing a little bit of
fatty you know what i would do have you
ever had like the um um
broccoli sort of slaw where they slice
this broccoli really thin you can get it
in the grocery store have you all seen
it do you know what i'm talking about i
do but
where that goes a little farty
this goes a little like acidic and
vibrant it's very citrus forward it's
real fresh what about some red onion
yeah i would love a red onion and i
think there might be a little cashew uh
blended on into the dressing too and
that's what's giving it the crease
there's your cream this is amazing okay
we're going to put this on our website
because it's all over tik tok and i
finally see what all the fuss is about
[Music]
you